it's essentially a cult it's it's a cult
of people
who are hiding the secrets of the world
from the rest of the people so that the
people can live
continuing their everyday uh slog
through their nine to five lives and not
consider
the possibility of more
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi i'm connor i'm a flat earther i was
debating a scientist earlier this year
on lab bible
stationary and flat versus uh globular
and moving
yeah right i'm looking around
i feel like i'm standing still and i'm
back just to reply to some of the
comments
all right let's do it i guess if the
earth is flat why hasn't anyone
fallen off yet it's the idea that you're
on a disc
in the middle of space in a vacuum and
if you just walk off this disc you're
gonna just start floating into
nowhere from a flat earth perspective we
live within an
enclosed system whether or not that
means there's a physical
uh container or is it a force
is it a force of nature is it
electromagnetism is it you know
that there are different explanations as
to how we could be contained if you're
going west
right you're gonna end up going in a
complete circle if you just stayed west
the entire time just like if you were on
a globe
because of the positioning of the north
pole what is beyond the border of the
flat earth oh i wish i knew
i wish i knew that that would be
something it would be great to find out
i would love to one day explore and find
out whether or not you know
uh anything to do with antarctica is the
way we thought it was
whether or not it's the edge of the
earth it's in my eyes it's one of two
things
right it's either we find the container
we find the edge so to speak whatever is
keeping us locked here
or we don't find any edge at all and we
just
keep going we've been fighting for the
entirety of human
existence for land and resources
so imagine you're the first or you
discover
that beyond a point there's more of this
and you have the money to keep that a
secret you have the influence to keep
that a secret from other people
it's it's a no-brainer to do that it's
essentially a cult
it's it's a cult of people who are
hiding
the secrets of the world from the rest
of the people so that the people can
live
continuing their everyday slog through
their nine to five lives and not
consider the possibility of more okay
what about flat mars are all planets
flat stars or is
only the earth flat the misconception
here is that we still exist in this
solar system with all these other
spheres so you're
you're still putting geocentrism into
your model
i don't believe anyone's ever been to
space i don't even think space in the
way that we see it exists i don't think
you can just go
into a vacuum somewhere i don't think
that that that whole thing has been
completely fabricated you can't go to
land on mars you can't land on the moon
you
these are not spherical rocks just
sitting in a vacuum
um they're they're the lights in the sky
as as stars are maybe the product of
sonoluminescence may be something else
but certainly not
terra firma that you can go land on so
is mars flat
well it's not a physical object as far
as we can determine
if the earth is flat how can planes fly
from say america to asia
in either direction they're basically
talking about circumnavigation
circumnavigation is
entirely possible uh both on the globe
model and the flat model the best way to
uh look at this i guess is is to look at
it from the ae perspective
if you consider the earth like the north
pole
at the top of the globe is now in the
center and the
continents are sprawled out so you've
basically taken the globe
you've flattened it and taken the south
and the south so antarctica and put it
around the the size of the plane
if the north pole is here and i'm here
on a globe
right then i can fly this way
and get to asia or i can fly this way
and get to asia left around west or east
i'm getting to asia
put on a flat model it's the same thing
if i go
west this way and my north pole is here
if i'm going west this way
i get to asia if i go east this way i'm
going to get to asia
it's the same thing it's just how you
look at it okay so
i saw this comment actually he actually
said it's flat the whole way around
let that sink in for a minute plenty of
pilots who fly
passenger jets who will tell you that
it's it's it's flat the whole way around
they're not interested in actually
hearing what i'm saying they're only
interested in attempting
to discredit me there was actually a
reply to that comment that it wasn't
by me but i saw it and it would you know
it showed
what i was trying to say very clearly
it's flat the whole way around
your view i wasn't saying it's flat the
whole way around the ball
that's it you know it's very easy to
discredit someone by just taking a quote
and then trying to you know
make it seem like what's being said has
bears no relevance or is contradictory
the flat earthers already disproved
themselves
with the laser tests in that documentary
like a year ago
so why is anyone still debating this
okay
i'm assuming you mean behind the curve
the netflix
documentary the whole thing was a hit
piece in order to make flat earth look
ridiculous and the people involved um i
know that there was a laser test that
was inconclusive
just because something is inconclusive a
test is inconclusive
it's not proof either way it's
inconclusive so
what kind of evidence would convince a
flat earther they keep asking for it but
deny it every time
if it proves them wrong i don't think
that's true i've seen no
evidence to say okay yeah the curvature
exists i would love to be shut up
i would love for you know any
uh agency to allow an independent
investigation of those lands
and then say with the whole thing you
know it turned out oh
you know it was complete it was complete
a lie flat earth is a lie
they're all just crazy people i'd love
to see that proof
because it could go either way but you
know
i don't think it's going to happen
because i think they're hiding something
there i think it's clear as day that
they're hiding something there
okay let's say scientists accept
that the earth is flat uh and what will
flat earthers do next like
what are their plans what do they want i
just can't understand this
this guy's comment makes it sound like
we're keeping him hostage or something
at a ransom for information look
scientists accepting that the earth is
flat mainstream scientists
science it'll never happen say that it
did right um
well then it's not about what flat
earthers do next it's about what the
world does next by saying that actually
yeah the earth is flat
then what what what is nasa what is jaxa
what is the antarctic treaty what have
we been doing in schools what has been
going on why has this
been fed to us why is this lie in this
narrative being fed to us so
that wouldn't just be flat earthers
asking that that would be the world
asking that and then the
implications of that are widespread am i
too stupid to understand the flat
earther or too smart to understand the
flat earther
probably neither you just have to be
willing to let go
or to kind of put to one side your
preconceived notions of what you think
flat earth to be whether you agree with
it or not after you understand it that's
up to you but
at least you'll be able to understand
why people think the way that they do
i could tell within the first uh two
seconds who the flatter
flat earther was yeah i mean well i
wasn't dressed like a school teacher in
a suit so that makes a lot of sense
i just came in and a hat and a shirt
also you know the thumbnail
the thumbnail of the video you know i
look like insane they must have screen
grabbed the most insane part of me they
could have and put it as
put it as the thumbnail of the video he
was either homeschooled or as a trump
supporter
or both neither it wasn't homeschooled
i know you're trying to also paint trump
supporters as
all being idiots i guess by making me
the idiot and saying if you're
homeschooled you're an idiot if you're a
trump supporter you're an idiot it's
just generalization right
so it's pretty uh idiotic to generalize
as well but that's just me
this is the difference between getting
your knowledge from studying and getting
it from youtube videos you know what's
funny
do you ever remember being in science
class and
your whole science class was someone
wheeling out a tv
and putting a bill nye video in and you
just watched bill nye for that
for that uh you know uh whole class
you can listen to something that's
educational and that gives you actual
genuine information
actionable information doesn't mean you
have to believe everything that's on
youtube you couldn't if you tried
but it's just a platform that people put
content onto you can agree or disagree
with that content arguing with a genius
is hard
arguing with an idiot is near impossible
that's very true
that's the i have no problem with that
statement at all i'm assuming you're
you're putting me as the idiot that's
fine if you want to see me as an idiot
because you disagree with something i'm
saying or that you think that your
beliefs are so
settled and indisputable then that's
fine you can believe me to be the idiot
i have no problem with that
you know it's i'm not gonna miss sleep
at night because you think that i'm an
idiot
it doesn't affect me but if you don't
argue with people and you don't have
healthy debate
and you don't listen to what someone
else has to say you're never going to
learn anything
then who's the idiot after that
the old man is actually amanda's all
about her once the reason he doesn't
talk about it
is because maybe he doesn't know how to
talk about it and the people like him
that are my age that don't talk about
mental health
because they don't want to be a [ __ ]
they then
suffer and then they kill themselves
because they think that they're being a
[ __ ] by talking about it
and all that bs so to blow me in trumpet
to blow me in bugle and blue smoke up my
own
i'm the opposite to a [ __ ] because i'm
actually talking about it
and because i want to help people become
stronger